something like this pops up every few
months and before we get into today's
video I would like to state that usually
I don't even see it I will have no idea
if there's some Twitter Thread about me
or Reddit or 4chan or whatever else
unless I am told my mentions are so
filtered that I won't see you tag me
like I literally just have no idea this
is even happening and if people do tell
me enough that it's happening I
generally don't care and the reason for
that is because I frankly feel like I am
too old and I felt that way for a long
time like I'm not worried about what
someone's saying about me on YouTube or
on Twitter I am a grown woman with bills
to pay I'm worried about taxes my sister
had a baby yesterday like I couldn't be
less concerned about like what some
dudes are tweeting you know so I don't
ever read any content about myself at
all but this one time I wanted to make a
video about it
um just to like say my piece because
this is starting to happen so frequently
then I'm like let's just let me just say
the thing and then get back out and like
go back to minding my own business
because it was another guy who was like
I'm so sorry about what all the
PlayStation Brazilian fans have been
saying to you I don't speak Portuguese
hey wouldn't have known it was a thing
if you haven't told me B wouldn't have
understood it thank you that is a nice
thing to say but literally will not know
it exists unless you tell me you just I
prefer you just don't tell me I'm good
that is the most important thesis of
this video but there's another thing
that I want to say as well so a
particularly upstanding citizen of the
internet here uh tweeted this in
response to me playing Starfield they
said a lot of PS should be fired for
promoting Xbox games on a public
platform like this extremely
unprofessional and demonstrates a lack
of loyalty and seriousness to
PlayStation her employer at Herman Holst
at Corey Paul which as an aside Corey
and I spent about 10 minutes before
meeting today talking about the stuff
we've been doing in Starfield and how
much we were enjoying it so good luck
with that one I'm also quite confident
that if I DM termin and we're like hey
how are you liking Starfield he'd be
like it's great but yes Bethesda didn't
share this with me and my reply was you
don't need to share it with me like
never feel like you need to share this
with me I don't care and it happens all
the time actually there was one time
that it happened uh where I didn't even
know it was happening um that a bunch of
people were very mad at me because I
loved tunic until Phil Spencer dm'd me
and was like I'm sorry this is happening
it's like I didn't even I didn't even
know I would never know unless you told
me but yes we're going to talk about it
very quickly today just to like get it
out there about like how absurd this
misconception is and then I'll just get
back to playing video games because
that's what I do so for reference I do
have this person blocked which is very
uncommon I only have 700 people blocked
on Twitter and you know I have 500 000
followers like I do not block many
people at all I would say 50 of those
blocks are because somebody did
something and I found it funny to block
them sometimes there are people who I
suspect like this one I'm not actually
sure I don't know who this is people
will warn me about like I'll have enough
people be like hey this person is doing
this or like harassing you you or
whatever and they've done it frequently
enough that I will just go and block
them based on someone telling me to like
I haven't even seen the stuff myself I'm
like okay I've registered that enough
people are mentioning this that I should
probably block this person in any case
the replies to the Tweet are quite funny
you're just like they had to turn their
replies off because people were dunking
on them so hard for this absurd take and
it is absurd this is like just
ridiculous and I'm sure most of you know
that but um there have been some sane
people who've asked me questions about
how this works as well and I'm like let
me just address it I work at Santa
Monica Studio and I love working there
it's the best job I've ever had I'm so
happy that I love my job I love the
people I work with like I think I work
at one of the best game studios in the
entire world that is my honest opinion
of working in SMS I think the studio is
incredible and I work with so many
people who have so much talent and
experience and like like I said I think
some of the best in the entire industry
that is my stance on the place that I
work similarly I also have friends who
work at Bethesda and I have friends who
work at Xbox and I have friends who work
at Nintendo when you work in the
industry for a long time I'm over 10
years now you end up making friends who
work a lot of places and I think one
thing that people don't realize is that
the console Wars don't really exist
inside the industry in fact there are
people on my direct team at Santa Monica
Studio who came from Xbox who just
worked at an Xbox Studio Santa Monica
you will have people leave who will then
go to work at Microsoft own Studios like
I get that these like console Fanboys
think that there's like this constant
War but the truth is the games industry
has people sharing around all the time
between many of these companies because
there are only so many jobs available in
game development and if there's anything
consistent for all of the people that I
know who work at PlayStation or who work
at Nintendo or who work at Xbox it's
that they don't care the reality of
working in game development or at least
my reality this is my experience of
course other people may have had
different experiences I'd be very
surprised if any of it differs very much
not talking about people who work in PR
and marketing whose like job it is to
sell the brand that's not my job all I
actually care about is doing my job and
doing it well if course I want people to
like the stuff I'm working on and of
course I want it to be successful but I
pretty similarly want every other game
in the industry to be the same way
working in the games industry is amazing
and exciting and and I've been in it for
as long as I have because I love video
games but it's exciting because
realistically the technology is actually
in its infancy like we're still figuring
out what we're doing people are making
huge leaps every year the way video
games look now is gonna look so
different in 50 years time because the
industry still has so much room to
progress frankly I see video games as
like almost Limitless because as the
hardware progresses video games can
progress like we can't even fathom the
kind of games that we'll be playing in
20 years everything is about technical
limitation and there is not necessarily
a cap
on Hardware progression thus there is
not necessarily really a cap on Game Dev
progression so when a big game comes out
and people are excited about it the
whole industry is excited about it I am
excited for my friends who work at Xbox
like I said virtually every Dev when
something like this happens is just
excited about it like a big Blockbuster
game that's taken 10 years to make and
has a huge budget like everyone else is
like oh my God I can't wait to play it
let's play it Corey they tagged him but
somebody else shared a tweet what Corey
is talking about how excited he was to
play style field like what did you think
was gonna happen it's so absurd the
people in the games industry like and
care about video games as a whole I am
not concerned about sales or pieces of
Hardware or content I am concerned about
doing my job well and making a good
video game and enjoying what everyone
else makes too I have always loved Xbox
and PlayStation and Nintendo I used to
work at Xbox I have two Nintendo tattoos
I currently work at PlayStation it would
not surprise me if I continue to work
for all three of these companies as I
continue in the games industry because I
love all of them I love the stuff they
make I love the they're making different
things like I'm just so happy to be here
and it is not my job or the job of
anyone like me to worry about like
stylefield being successful and all like
I just want other video games to be
successful especially when this single
player and don't have Micro transactions
like that is the kind of games that I
want to make forever so I always want
every other game in the games industry
that follows that same pattern to be as
successful as possible I want it to be a
commercial success and so like all these
console Fanboys who care about this like
again I know most of you don't and most
of you are rational people people who
actually work into game development
everybody's just excited about video
games man like they don't care who made
them they're just happy that all their
friends who work in Dev made something
cool and like of course you have
multiple people who jump between
companies so you will end up working
with someone who worked at Bethesda I
end up working with somebody who worked
at Santa Monica Studio like it's just
the way the industry works the stuff
that you think matters does not matter
it maybe matters to a marketing
department or a PR department I don't
know but I can also tell you a little
bit of my experience with the marketing
PR departments so when I worked at Xbox
play Playstation still gave me a
PlayStation 4 and they gave me early
access to games there was no hesitation
there whatsoever they still gave me
access to PlayStation stuff now I work
at PlayStation and Xbox kind of
hesitated a little to begin with and now
give me access to codes for XBox games
but they did used to give me like all
the cool stuff like the controllers and
stuff I don't get that stuff from them
anymore like I clearly like was moved
around a mailing list a little bit
PlayStation didn't care Nintendo also
didn't care they gave me everything when
I worked at Xbox didn't care at all and
nobody at PlayStation or Sony at any
point ever has ever told me not to talk
about games on other platforms in
reality the thing that I do have
restrictions on is promoting PlayStation
I no longer get early access to
PlayStation games I can't do an early
impressions of a PlayStation game I
can't do like my first hour gameplay of
a PlayStation game I have to buy all my
PlayStation games and I buy them on
release there was an ad uh agency in
Australia that wanted to pay me to make
part of an ad for Ratchet and client
because they knew I was super excited
about rushing Clank Rift apart but I
guess somebody at Sony said no I think
it's like a totally respectable ethical
stance of like you can talk about Xbox
and Nintendo all you want they have
never said anything that would in any
way disparage me from doing so or
discourage me doing so I just can't get
early access to anything PlayStation
related and I don't get the like fun
mailer kits that a lot of my friends who
work in in uh media get like they get
like the newest PlayStation controllers
that they share on social media I don't
get any of that kind of stuff it's like
the opposite of what you think it is as
for if I'm biased towards Playstation or
Xbox the truth is people have been
saying this about me in either direction
and both directions so passionately for
as long as I have been speaking about
video games people have called me a
PlayStation show for the last 10 years
and people have called me an Xbox show
for the last 10 years it depends which
side you're on I have PlayStation fans
get very mad at me because I didn't talk
about PlayStation enough I have Xbox
fans get mad at me because apparently I
don't like certain games because they're
on Xbox the Starfield one's been extra
fun because it depends which side of the
camp you're on I really like this game
but I have some criticisms of it right
that's how I feel about it as a person
who just is here and enjoys video games
but because my stance is not like all
one or the other because I'm a human
being the Xbox fans like [__] you Sony
shill and then the PlayStation fans are
like [__] you you're obsessed with this
game you love it like they don't realize
that they're both saying the literal
opposite thing and I don't care if
people think I'm biased again it's been
happening forever think whatever you
want but the actual reality of where I
land in the video game landscape
um as much as I'm sure it's annoying for
a lot of people who are console Fanboys
is honestly just that I love video games
I love X Xbox I love PlayStation I love
Nintendo I just really love video games
that is how I feel and I want them all
to be good and I'm so happy when any of
them are good especially again if
they're single player microtransaction
free experiences that is my stance
you're gonna criticize me for anything
it would be that sometimes I get too
excited like I can get a bit carried
away with how excited I am about certain
things and obviously I share that and if
I have influence on you you could end up
being also very excited but I can't like
turn that off like I'm just happy to be
here man and of course saying this is
not going to change the minds of any of
these people like I know that but I yeah
I did want to be clear about the fact
that like wow why is she allowed to talk
about Starfield so much like even sane
people have been saying that like people
who are not all over the console war
Brigade it's not a thing there's nobody
at Sony is ever going to tell me that I
shouldn't talk about Starfield people
have wondered if there were restrictions
I'm like no of course not there are no
restrictions on me liking video games
all you will ever see from the dev
Community is people supporting other
people's games it's so weird that you
like forget that when there's a big
release like it's all over Twitter
people with PlayStation and people at
Nintendo are loving Starfield that's
just the way it is you get excited about
the industry and just like happy to be a
part of it so in conclusion I don't care
about this stuff and you don't need to
share it with me I prefer if you didn't
most of the time it's not worth it
second point is the console more stuff
that you all think matters so much
doesn't actually matter to anyone On My
Level we all just love video games and
are excited about video games and new
video games being good and having a good
time at video games but no there are no
restrictions uh and no one has ever said
anything to me at all about how much I
like an Xbox game or how much I like a
Nintendo game now we can pretend this
never happened it's done I'm not gonna
get fired because I liked
Xbox or Nintendo I'm so sorry